some sad news tonight the player who
epitomized the toughness of the 1960s
and70s National Football League has died
Chicago Bears Hall of Fame linebacker
dick bugus died peacefully in his sleep
overnight at his California home
according to a family statement tonight
he was named to the all NFL first team
six times he went on to have a
successful acting career dick buckus was
80 years old sure that'll be mentioned
tonight at the Commander Chicago Bears
game hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now